so the ladylike ladies of buzzfeed
decided they were going to paint with
their period blood
oh gosh furthermore it was featured on
the youtube homepage these women
painting with their period blood
uh now here's the deal you have every
right to paint with your period blood
but we have the right to say
that's gross and we don't want to watch
you paint with your period blood without
being accused of patriarchy
and here's the ultimate irony this isn't
really edgy when it comes to art they
did it to shock and offend it's
it's actually a level or two behind the
piss christ which you know got people
really mad that piece of art there's
nothing edgy about painting with your
menstruation
and getting it featured in the homepage
of youtube but one to always push the
envelope when it comes to art and
inspired by the ladies at buzzfeed
he is not the hero we deserve but the
one we need
bob ross
[Music]
welcome to the joy of painting i'm bob
ross to this very special
buzzfeed ladylike inspired edition we're
always open here at the joy of painting
to
new and inventive ways to express
yourself so with the help of artist sara
levy we're taking period shame and
flipping it on its head
it's ladylike and today we are painting
with our menstrual blood
illuminating and inspiring so today
we're going to be painting a portrait in
some period blood
now the beauty with period blood is that
it's a little more diverse and some
people might think
and we're going to do a portrait instead
of a landscape because
menstruation is what gives the gift of
life
human life so we want to draw a human
life paint human life
we're going to mix the menstruation here
and get a little bit of crimson
i'm going to draw my man in just a
little bit of crimson
there we go now you can have crimson you
can have ruby red
sometimes you have a move scattered with
off-white you never know what you're
gonna get
and the beauty of painting with
menstruation is we
are recycling
mother nature said hey eggs we
think you're no good here mother nature
thought they were useless but here they
are
serving a purpose as we paint in period
blood
thank you ladies of buzzfeed here i'm
going to give my man here
a little red tree and look at that tree
yeah that's a blazing autumn maple tree
its leaves are falling
just like the rejected ovaries in this
period blood
and also thanks to youtube for inspiring
this video
through featuring the buzzfeed ladylike
women
video painting in their period if
youtube hadn't force-fed this into my
subscription feed we'd never be here
right now
millions of plays millions have placed
because youtube decided that
everyone wants to see us painting with a
little period blood
oh the man looks lonely let's draw him a
little friend
in the period blood and what a lovely
painting that is
look at that that's the beauty of art
with nothing more than
sloughed off egg sales women's
menstruation we managed to create a
wonderful portrait of muhammad the
holiest prophet peace be upon him
beating the hell out of a six-year-old
child pride aisha
who might have been too young to
menstruate herself but
never too young to be painted in period
blood
for the joy of painting i'm bob ross
happy painting
and god bless you my friend
[Music]
if you like this video subscribe by
clicking the subscribe button it's
in a circle now it used to be a square
which most buttons aren't squares unless
it's on a phone
there's square buttons on phones but
most buttons are circles you understand
what i'm talking about or watch the
recommended video which is popping up in
a box or subscribe at
liverworthrider.com
mug club join the mug club so you can
get the daily show and that means that
you are not beholden to the youtube
censoring overlords let's be honest
you like being there where you are under
their thumb
power bottom you